every time I grant a trigonometric
function which has been modified in some
way the priests you've got it begin is
posted on Monday morning it the original
version of the graph before it was
modified and then you think about it
what where you need to change it and
then measure exact so here's regular
tennis okay I have drawn it from North
intrinsics Alexa 10x is a little bit
different from same cosine and its
period is not 360 degrees what is the
period of time it's 180 and you can see
if I divide it right then down the
middle
do you see that to the left of the black
line and sort of like the back line
they're identical easier if you get the
copy and then you get another copy okay
now just keep that in the back of your
mind when you come and see this right
the way I would write this is - own
minor difference but it helps me
remember Lexi's expression what this
thing is doing it is just like an X but
it's working at one side of the street
okay it's been stretched out three times
further because it's going at a third of
the progression okay so for example have
a look at where my first Adam - you see
that and 90 degrees this guy take a lot
longer than the 90 degree to get their
attention
it takes you three times longer so the
asymptotes for this graph that appears
first will not be x equals maybe will
actually then X equal to seven okay
that's the first passenger now when I
figure out a third basic what you're
doing is take this four not centricity
what's the third of three sixty
something twenty right so all you have
to do is take this guy and taking up to
120 degrees that's how much of tan X
you'll get for this gun exactly a third
now I want to cut me out this is 180
here okay the roughly place 120 where
would you put it
this is Nigeria here right what's
exactly halfway between nineteen one is
exactly halfway I'm pretty sure it's 135
right that's not the angle I want
actually in normal 120 you have to
divide it into thirds right roughly
anywhere okay commendatory 30 30 30
right so where is the 120 line let me
show you there we go
that's 120 degree like it's 90 plus a
little bit 120 and it stops at that
reason awkward position okay now what
you just won that's the graph you're
supposed to do except it's not 4 not 120
Italy is stretched answers okay so I'm
just going to really quickly draw out my
new cinematically and can you see I can
roughly break this up into quarters you
see 500 30 60 90 120 right to break that
thing up into quarters the reason I
quoted it in points is because I
normally break this thing up into
quarters right 90 180 270 360 okay so
that thing is going to stretch out all
the way to here 360 except that wall I
go where's the vertical asymptote you
are in Thomas 277 here
okay it's not so good that shapingg
there is what I get
before I get the awesome tip so it
stretches up like that okay then you get
this wee bit over here which sort of
starts and injures with like that do you
agree that this is just a stretched out
version of that so concentrate okay
now I've done the bare bones of it I
just go put in a little details fill it
out on 10x I usually have a point to
scale with my normal points this game 45
degree the F Sony had one for the Y that
is slightly on why this new graphic God
is three times slower so instead of
taking 45 degrees to get there what's
three times 4535 right 135 should be
there right so by the time you get to
135 oh Allah now you're in one different
places game okay but because of the way
up slice the graph I will just slice it
here and I need to know what these
studies thankfully I know what the X is
so I can work out the windup y equals
tan of 360 degrees on three - see that's
my X on three yep that's 10 and 120
degrees okay Big C this is in which
quadrant in the second quarter so
therefore whatever it's going to be
acting in is negative it is very
negative will see down here later how I
work at the actual value what's that
what's the base angle or the related the
acute angle to relate this depends on
now I know you can shut this in your
calculator if you want but you really
need to practice knowing what these
things are okay so I'm going to draw
30-60-90 someone tell me what sides to
closes we're not there one through two
one two because sine 30 is hot hot
yes chase block one and three okay 1060
Q readable opposite want a danger yes -
so now I know where this is
here we go there you go which because of
the she wants to miss my grass 12.7 not
bad considering I just kind of freak a
minute okay because you are doing it on
there where the ruler of lies and I got
to be really attracted to give that
distance roughly life because that scale
needs to be consistent does that make
sense